moi j'ai pas eu de qu'est-ce que c'est
un truc qui vous avez une bestiole qui
alors voilà c'est on va on va souhaiter
vous souhaiter une bonne nuit à vous et
puis oh là là là
vous avez une souris dans la main
en fait c'est pas une souris c'est un
rat
é
alors ça c'est la version courte on
verra la version dans un instant et je
suis très heureux d'avoir sur notre
plateau un garçon que j'adore qui fait
de la télé d'ailleurs qui a fait la télé
chez nous sur C8 mais qui est conseillé
un journaliste de France qui était
excellent d'ailleurs merci Pierre
merci d'être là
pierre et c'est vrai que j'ai besoin de
toi parce que c'est un garçon très
sérieux pierre et qui va nous donner des
voilà des vrais infos aujourd'hui tu es
conseillers régional de France est-ce
qu'il y a un vrai problème de rat à
Paris et dans la région et voilà est-ce
que est-ce que c'est où est-ce que je me
fais une idée à Paris particulièrement
il faut bien avoir en tête qu'il y a 2
millions de Parisiens il y a 6 millions
de bras population estimée alors en soi
les rats c'est pas gênant dans la mesure
où ils sont sous terre en souterrains
dans les égouts dans le réseau des goûts
d'ailleurs ils sont assez utiles dans
les réseaux des goûts parce qu'ils
viennent un peu débouchés là tuyauterie
comme grosso modo donc c'est c'est
non là où ça devient problématique c'est
quand ils arrivent en surface et quand
ils arrivent en surface en nombre et en
fait à Paris depuis un certain nombre
d'années maintenant on voit on voit les
rats justement arriver en surface
massivement en surface et là c'est
problématique ces problématique parce
que les races sont
propagateur de maladies c'est ça c'est
dangereux tout simplement on a beau dire
moi ce qui me fait peur aussi c'est dans
les parcs pour enfants pour enfants
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que tu mets tes
enfants jouer ils vont jouer dans les
marques tu sais pas il y a des souris il
y a des rats et c'est porteurs de
maladie c'est vrai que ça moi c'est ça
qui me qui me dérange aussi Paris
aujourd'hui c'est
une ville infestée on a droit à combien
de rap par habitant
faites le calcul on pourra aller
si les plombiers
pour une population de 2 millions mais
c'est vrai que voilà on en rigole mais
c'est vrai que nous moi je vous dis je
n'ai jamais vu autant de rats que on a
l'impression d'avoir partout maintenant
que c'est c'est c'est avant tu disais
c'était rare mais dans tous les
restaurants une fois sur deux tu vois
une souris ou un rat mais si elle vous
avait parlé des des jardins des parcs
des espaces verts tous ces espaces là
aujourd'hui il grouille littéralement il
grouille les espaces verts mais aussi
désormais les rues on l'envoie assez
régulièrement à tomber du soir on va
traverser
ça n'est pas un fait rare que de voir
des rats aujourd'hui à Paris mais c'est
ça ça donne aussi une idée de de l'état
d'un seul d'insalubrité chronique de la
ville parce qu'en fait le problème c'est
pas tant qu'il y aura qui sont au
sous-sol ou qui est quelques rats qui de
temps en temps viennent en surface le
problème c'est quand vous avez des rats
qui massivement viennent en surface et
ça veut dire qu'on est on a atteint un
stade de crasse un stade de saleté un
stade d'insalubrité qui est inédit et
qu'on voit d'ailleurs dans aucune ville
au monde et la deuxième réflexion que ça
me que ça me que ça me m'évoque c'est
que c'est pas nouveau ces images de rats
qui font le tour des médias qui font
malheureusement le tour du monde aussi
c'est toute l'image de Paris c'est toute
la rayonnement de Paris
c'est l'image de Paris à l'international
qui en prend un coup parce que ces
images-là malheureusement surtout quand
elles sont relayées par des touristes
qui font des Tik Tok au pied de la Tour
Eiffel avec des poubelles qui grouillent
etc ou le Champ de Mars qui est infesté
ça fait le tour du monde ça fait le tour
du monde donc il faut ça fait quelques
années maintenant il est grand temps de
trouver des solutions des solutions
pérennes et malheureusement il n'y a
qu'une seule solution pourra vous dire
ouais on a dépensé les millions d'euros
pour dératiser non non faut pas
dératiser c'est quoi les Russes soient
propres faut que ça soit propre quand
vous avez une ville ou quoi tant que
vous avez une ville qui est propre vous
avez pas drap en surface Paris
aujourd'hui c'est la seule capitale
occidentale à connaître un tel fléau
est-ce que c'est pas une honte une honte
pour pour la capitale de la France je te
jure mais c'est vrai et c'est aussi à
cause des nombreux travaux que la lancée
maire de Paris aussi les travaux les
travaux font effectivement
remonter à la surface parce que vous
faites des perforations dans le sol le
problème les travaux en soi c'est pas
gênant encore une fois le problème des
travaux le pardon les travaux sont pas
gênants en soi le problème c'est quand
vous avez des travaux qui sont
désorganisés et quand vous faites des
trous partout dans la chaussée et que
ces trous par manque de moyens parce que
le budget voirie est exemple vous mettez
du temps à l'air boucher donc là ça fait
à cause de cette de cette arrivée
massive de grande surface à Paris c'est
l'insalubrité chronique de la ville
c'est tout c'est tout on a beau essayer
de mettre des pièges à ras on a beau
dératisé balancer un peu de vapeur d'eau
dans les dans les dans les trous dans
les jardins publics ça ne sert à rien ça
ne sert à rien six millions de rats ça
sert à rien vous allez faire des pièges
à rats vous allez capturer une trentaine
une cinquantaine de rats il faut
nettoyer cette ville il faut nettoyer de
ville Paris et la seule concernée
accessoirement vous regardez les autres
villes alentours le problème il n'existe
pas vous regardez les grandes villes
françaises qui sont aussi des métropoles
qui sont aussi des villes qui qui à Lyon
on n'a pas ce problème nulle part vous
l'avez dit Paris c'est dans l'esprit de
beaucoup c'est la plus belle ville du
monde aujourd'hui c'est la poubelle
ville du monde Paris bravo bravo
[Musique]
oui on pourrait pas quand même essayer
d'un peu d'en exterminer quelques-uns ça
servait à rien de lancer une grande
campagne ou voilà
essayer d'en tuer un petit peu quand
même parce que là il y en a beaucoup
trop encore une fois alors les rack
aiment beaucoup
les 6 millions estimés c'est estimé
c'est-à-dire que une portée c'est pas un
rat par an enfin une femelle c'est pas
un parent c'est une flopée et non mais
la question n'est pas tant de les
exterminer de les exterminer vous dites
que de les maintenir là où ils doivent
être là où il leur place leur place
c'est dans les égouts alors c'est c'est
ragoutant pour le coup c'est peu mais
c'est dans les égouts ça a une utilité
dans les égouts il faut que ça reste il
faut que les rats restent dans les
égouts à partir du moment où ils sont
trop nombreux en surface là il y a un
problème
mais ce qu'il y a donc des solutions
concrètes si vous pouviez donner des
idées à la mère de Paris justement
concrètement qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
il faut travailler plus main dans la
main avec les éboueurs est-ce qu'il faut
sensibiliser les gens est-ce qu'il faut
mettre plus de poubelles est-ce qu'il
faut travailler moins dans la main avec
eux
on peut lancer le débat sur la propreté
de Paris c'est un vrai débat un vrai
sujet je sais pas si on a le temps ce
soir mais ce qui est ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la ville de Paris
consacre chaque année 500 millions
d'euros dans la propreté un demi
milliard d'euros c'est cool
et la mère de Paris a annoncé à sa
réélection doubler ce budget pour le
passer à un milliard le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien que ce
budget cet argent il est mal utilisé
parce que on n'a jamais mis autant
d'argent dans la propreté et la ville
n'a jamais été aussi sale donc c'est pas
parce que vous allez doubler cet argent
qui est mal géré que la ville sera
doublement mieux gérée donc à un moment
il faut la question sur quels sont les
moyens quels sont les méthodes quelles
sont les process et comment est-ce qu'on
fait pour gérer tout ça donc la première
des choses à faire et on le voit dans
d'autres villes de France qui l'ont fait
et qui n'ont pas du tout ces problèmes
d'insalubrité chronique dans leur ville
c'est et là je vais lâcher un vrai gros
mot pour en tout cas pour la ville de
Paris peut-être certains d'entre vous
mais c'est faire appel au privé le privé
c'est très bien nettoyer des villes il y
a des villes il y avait
pas prêt
dans cette émission on peut pas tout
dire vas-y molo pierre là tu vas là
franchement là j'avais que comprendre
qu'il y a des sujets un peu tabous non
mais là franchement là c'est gaffe donc
externaliser externaliser ça il y a
énormément de villes qui le font des
villes qui sont par ailleurs limitrophes
à Paris qui connaissent un peu les mêmes
les mêmes usages que Paris les mêmes
populations qui ont externalisé ces le
service public de la propreté ça
fonctionne bien vous allez à Boulogne
nous sommes à Boulogne ce soir vous
allez à Levallois-Perret vous allez à
Vincennes ce sont des villes limitrophes
les populations sont exactement les
mêmes que les Parisiens il y a rien qui
différencient un Parisien du 17e
arrondissement qu'un levalloisien vous
mangez par terre pourquoi est-ce qu'à
Paris c'est dégueulasse exactement alors
je vous dis à quelqu'un qui nous dit que
le tournage n'était pas à Paris la
Boulogne mais je veux dire ça n'a rien à
voir c'est que le rat métro vient du
métro donc il est venu de Paris pour le
ramener à Boulogne faut dire que
Boulogne il y a pas plus propre comme
dit et je rigole pas il y a pas plus
propre alors je peux vous dire on
mangerait par terre et je mange derrière
par terre je suis Boulonnais je peux
vous dire que à Boulogne les rats ne
viennent pas du tout ils je le vois les
rails je je les connais et voilà
faut sexe qui leur donne une carte quoi
alors on les interdit de métro de RER de
tout pardon si tu me permets parce que
j'ai vu effectivement que ces images
cette image là avait été tournée à
Boulogne ce qui ce qui soulignent ça
veulent faire croire derrière quoi que
finalement il n'y a pas de Ré à Paris
c'est quoi l'obligation
des Halles avant toute la bouffe était
là c'était le paradis des il y avait des
lapins quoi
et ils sont pas non plus à Rungis mais
pour autant ils sont pas